this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode 23
with daryl cooper and me jocko willink
and it is currently
the last day of september
and we are reflecting
looking back
at august and september
and i think the entire time
we could have done a hundred episodes
you know maybe an episode a day or every
other day
as to everything that unfolded and
i was busy you were busy we're working
we're doing other things
but we get to this point where we
finally get a chance to
which might be beneficial i guess
that we get to look back and look back
at this situation
and say what just happened
what just happened with regards to this
afghanistan pull out
we see
the afghan military collapse we see the
afghan government collapse
we see
80 million dollars worth of weapons
vehicles equipment
3 000 humvees
32
mi
17 helicopters three c130s
43 md 530 helicopters 33
blackhawks
23 a29 light attack planes 10 ac 208
planes
20 000 grenades
somewhere around 10 000
small arms weapons
1400 rpgs
and
in my opinion perhaps the worst of all
between 10 000 and 15 000 sets of night
vision goggles all left behind
and on top of that during this pull out
we had 13 service servicemen and women
who were killed
just an unmitigated disaster
and
it got me to thinking and you know since
you and i weren't didn't do any work
during this you know i ended up doing
that video of
what i would say if i was president
and there's two things that pushed me to
make that video of what i would say if i
was president
um the first one was
seeing the iwo jima reenactment by the
taliban fully kitted up in american gear
i saw that and i had the sort of
visceral anger emotional reaction to
that
and and i had to put that in check kind
of i said look you know don't be
emotional these are just
idiots this is just what they're doing
they're they're trying to throw it in
our face they're trying to get to you
know trying to make us emotional
don't react so i didn't
but
as soon as i started seeing these
caches of
weapon systems vehicles planes i thought
to myself hold on a second here
what the [ __ ] did we just do
it was ha it's hard enough to fight the
taliban
or al-qaeda
when they're when they've got the
advantage of not having any roes when
they don't care about friendly fire when
they don't care about civilian
casualties
when they can hit and run
when they don't have to hold any ground
when they can fade into the night when
they can use our roes against never mind
the fact that they don't have arrows but
they use our ros against us so it's bad
enough to fight an enemy like that but
now we have an enemy
that has the same weapon systems as we
have never mind the helicopters never
mind the
the the armored vehicles
what about
just seeing a mark 48 machine gun and
knowing the effectiveness of that weapon
and then there's a laser mounted on it
and the and the mujahideen fighters are
wearing night vision
so at that point is when i said yeah i
need to talk about what we should be
doing right now as a country
now that i'm looking back a little bit
like i said it's the end of september
right now
and you hear some of the testimony
taking place some of the excuses being
made some of the thought process that
went into this or did not go into this
and and it makes you start to wonder
makes me start to wonder did we have we
forgotten how to win
because a freaking lance corporal
in the marine corps could have planned
this operation better
no no offense against lance corporals in
the marine corps they're squared away
they're awesome
but they don't have a bunch of strategic
experience
they don't even have a bunch of
operational experience but you know what
they do understand how to plan a mission
and a lance corporal that had been in
the marine corps for six months could
have done a better job planning this
than what we saw
what'd you think dc
well i am glad like you are that we um
happened to be busy over the last month
so that we waited i'm no less angry in
fact i'm probably angrier now
having seen the way
i don't know if i how i could have
expected anything otherwise but but the
way it's been responded to
the the deep knowledge at this point
that you know you suspected even at the
beginning but now it's just certainly
clear that nobody's going to be held
accountable for this not even
reputationally
is anybody going to be held accountable
for this and so
you know there's two questions it's like
one is what happened and two is like
what is what is happening overall
you know with the department of defense
sure but like our overall system of
government right now where something
like this could happen
and then be responded to in the way that
it has been i mean we've we've got
not just politicians i mean we've got
journalists people who like
theoretically in a situation like this
should be the ones we expect to hold
lying politicians accountable for for
something like this framing it as an
extraordinary success it's the miracle
of dunkirk all over again it's just
extraordinary how we managed to pull off
it's insulting these people are a joke
and
none of their excuses make sense you
know
with people with military and government
experience like we have it's it's
completely insulting knowing that they
are that they are providing excuses that
are meant for people who don't have that
experience who don't know any better and
they sort of hear things and it sounds
complicated and they just have to sort
of accept what they're told because they
don't know any better
you know when they tell us that uh well
we just we we thought that the afghan
security forces were well trained and
ready to go trained up to american
standards you know and ready to fight
the taliban lloyd austin general lloyd
austin at the time was in charge of
centcom until like 2017. don't tell me
he didn't have some idea what was going
on with the afghan forces that is
horseshit
and
it just it's insulting to hear it
you know as you go through the timeline
of how this whole thing unfolded it
becomes it becomes clear throughout that
you ask like have we forgotten how to
win that winning uh was not the priority
here i mean forget about winning we
already lost the war we're being chased
out of the country at this point you
know but
i think you go through it and it becomes
perfectly clear that preserving the
lives of uh let's just call them what
they were tens of thousands of american
and allied
hostages
that's what was going on here we had a
hostage situation you know where the
people that we had been told
were so bad we're so evil
we're so barbaric these taliban that it
is imperative that we spill american
blood
to defeat them and keep them out of
power in afghanistan and we spend
trillions of dollars and let our people
be killed and maimed to fight them
because they're they're that dangerous
you know and people who we've been
killing whose sons and cousins and
brothers and fathers we've been killing
like over the years
they're all of a sudden in complete and
total control of tens of thousands of
americans and allied and allied
civilians and and a country and the
country and and you know we're just sort
of told throughout the entire thing that
like well um you know we've been in
talks with them and uh you know
there's no threat right now there's a
cnn report that i'll never forget i mean
there's a million of these in my data
bank right now that like give me
nightmares by this point but like you
know where you had this the cnn reporter
and uh they're they're they're standing
as a bunch of uh hiluxes full of of uh
you know um taliban are driving by
chanting with their with their aks and
rpgs up in the air and they say uh you
know they're chanting death to america
but um are not being threatening at the
moment
it's like what are we doing here like
what are we talking about i mean this is
just think about the fact that like as
all this unfolded um the the white house
press secretary was on vacation and
didn't come back
she she went on her vacation and got
back when it was done new president
biden went to camp dave and people like
oh there's a situation room in camp by
camp david don't give me a crap
this is a situation you've got tens of
thousands of americans trapped with an
enemy that we've been fighting for 20
years
they're still over there right now you
know one of the things you go you go
looking like uh
go look up google you know americans
trapped in afghanistan americans still
stuck in afghanistan and so forth and
the whole first like page and a half two
pages are all links from like two weeks
ago because nobody nobody's really been
looking into it i guess no there's
there's still americans over there
there's actually still american
children
from here in san diego from down in
chula vista who are stuck over there who
you know who can't get home who's got
like there's a father over here who's
whose wife and their four daughters went
to visit family back in april they're
stuck over there right now and he's like
these are american citizens we're
talking about and they're still over
there and somehow that's not an
emergency
somehow it's not an emergency and it's
and let's just be perfectly honest it is
not an emergency to these people it is
not it's a it would become an emergency
when it became a public relations
problem and a political problem but they
made the calculation
that they can get through this you know
you even had those i think it was in
woodward's book um you know he had he
had uh president biden saying that uh
you know that that
1975 saigon didn't really hurt gerald
ford we can get through this too
and you know this is the way these
people think we are not led by statesmen
we are led by bureaucrats we are led by
by narcissistic politicians who at best
see their job as managing
a system you know that happens to be in
place you know they judge success by
whether or not policy is being followed
and whether the proper channels were
used to approve such and such and you
know whether this installation over here
has had maybe too many human rights or
rather uh human resources complaints and
you know if the overall organization is
uh you know meeting all of the equal uh
opportunity like sort of requirements
and if all of those things are true well
then everybody's doing their job never
mind that the outcome is a catastrophe
you know because nobody's responsible
for the outcome you know that nobody's
responsible and and every one of these
generals these these people if they had
any honor they would have
you know these people would have
resigned on their own uh whether they
were fired or not if they had an ounce
of honor after what's happened
especially after the suicide bombing and
when you read about how that whole day
played out um
you know but but they can go up there
and they can make the plausible case
they're like oh no i checked this box i
did that i reported to this person and
blah blah blah and so on and so forth
and it's disgusting and these people are
a joke and
you know if for for all the strategic
consequences and all of our reputational
consequences around the world i'll tell
you the truth i'm happy that we are out
of that country because i don't trust
these people
to command or to direct american you
know men and women in dangerous places
around the world right now they they
better not come talk to us again
about about going into any other country
where they're going to put our people at
risk until this generation of leaders
the whole generation of them you know i
don't mean republicans or democrats just
this whole this whole group of people
who gave us iraq who gave us afghanistan
and managed it the way that it was
managed
they all have to go these people are all
like 75 80 85 years old they got to get
the hell out of here and and they better
not put our people in harm's way until
they do it's just none of us should
accept it
i haven't watched all the testimony
that's been taking place over the last
couple days um just because i work
but
well one of the things that i saw kept
coming up is
you know this idea that we could we
didn't know
that the taliban would fall in seven
days six days five days nine days
whatever it was
but and then they say
we we thought it would be at least
two months at least three months and
you're thinking to yourself
what are you talking about like that was
your attitude and you still made the
same decisions that's like saying well
you know i didn't know when i left my
kid at home by himself that he was going
to burn the house down in an hour i
thought it would take
to take at least four or five hours so
that's why you know i when i left for
the weekend
you know i i guess it was a
i i did the best i could it's like wait
a second the kid was going to burn the
house down
whether it takes one hour or five hours
you still you if the house is burned
down we look at afghanistan it's like oh
we didn't know it's gonna take a week we
thought it would take at least three
months
so you thought that you were okay with
that is that what we're saying now
it's insane it's insane and it's insane
especially when you think of the fact
you know the the just the the cringing
uh just just just disgusting display
that got put on uh you know that
happened in the immediate aftermath is
all this was going on toward the end of
it and then afterwards where you had our
leaders you know going out there
president biden first among them and
people you know this is not political
he's in charge right now and if this was
anybody else i would go just as hard
going out there and just just going off
on the cowardice of the afghan security
forces and leaders and so forth it's
like
well
our own people are saying they're going
to collapse in three months and so is it
better to fight the taliban to the last
man and then suffer the consequences
when they win in three months or is it
like a you know a better idea to just
say we better they're giving us an
opportunity to get out of this
peacefully let's take it of course
that's a better idea um
you know it's it's
that that was one of the things that was
most stomach churning about the entire
thing like it's just
especially when you go through
the timeline of events again and you see
how all this was developing it's like
you said you know we didn't know we
didn't know we didn't know
a lot of people knew
okay you can go you can go read like
small words journal long war go read
like guys like uh tom jocelyn or bill
rojo guys who have been on the
afghanistan beat for years and years on
a detailed level
um you know there's a guy who a
podcaster he's a radio host on kfi up in
uh
up in uh la for for many years uh brian
suits who runs a podcast called the dark
secret place um talks about military
he's a veteran and uh he you know all
these guys there's tons of people who
like as may as events were unfolding in
may and june and july they're like oh
yeah this is over like the taliban are
coming and this the country is in
process of collapsing right now don't
tell me that nobody at the national
security council or any of these other
places was getting that report
if they weren't getting that report
they are freaking idiots
you know there's a agree a great quote
from hackworth was
one of the major problems of the vietnam
war is that the politicians listen to
the generals and the politicians only
listen to the generals and the generals
only listen to themselves
so even when you say lloyd austin was a
centcom commander in two in 2017
he had to have known it's like well it
depends on how much he insulated himself
because some people insulate themselves
to the point where they're only getting
a briefing from
other generals
and guess what that general wants to do
wants to tell a good story wants to tell
a positive story
now that's a lot of pressure up and down
the chain to do it all the way down to
the ground level to pencil with it right
when you start talking about the
government you know you kind of kind of
went hard on the government system
i mean you're seeing that not just in
this
afghanistan scenario but
we're starting to i mean look at the way
things are handled right now and the
methodology it's like another
it's like the new way to win
because i said do have we forgotten how
to win actually we've learned a new way
to win it seems like there's a new way
to win oh what we need to do is change
the rules
change the perspective
show people something from a different
angle and then you get the w yeah
yeah with it right i mean you were
talking what were you saying about the
school like the schools the um
the low graduation rates in california
how'd that play out well they just um
they took away the requirement for the
graduation exam and they started going
up it's amazing you know and they've
taken credit for that and people have
gotten promoted because of it you know
because the graduation rate has gone up
you know if the schools are a perfect
example you don't get too bogged down in
some of the other aspects of it but i
think it is important to recognize that
this is not like just a specific
department of defense or military
problem i think the department of
defense and the military are probably uh
you know some of the least
bad uh you know situations we have in
our bureaucracies right now i mean but
you know you look at the schools and you
say for decades just we're consistently
putting out large percentages of
students who were graduating without
basic skills
um you know for years la unified had um
la unified school district had a
graduation rate that hovered just you
know just under to just over 50
and you say okay um we're pumping more
and more money into these things every
single year um every year there's a new
white paper based on some new person's
research that like we're going to change
things to do this and that you say who's
responsible for the fact that that this
organization is not accomplishing its
mission and the answer is nobody is
nobody's responsible what's responsible
is the system the system's responsible
we're just bureaucrats we're managers
the system's responsible
well what's the system you can't
criticize the system the system is our
democracy the system is you know in in
in the case of afghanistan the men and
women of the armed forces or some other
sacred symbol that we're all like loath
to criticize and it's the you know and
and are used as shields for the people
who are actually making these decisions
to hide behind
you know and and it's it's just
it just drives you insane you know
because it
there's not even a hope
that anybody's going to be held remotely
responsible for any of this and it's the
most galling part of the entire thing i
was working with a company and they had
a paperwork submission process that
would take place for one of their
factories to be able to purchase a new
piece of equipment and
let's say you want to manufacture
something and you come to me at my my
factory inside this company say i want
to make this and i go okay cool but i
got to buy a piece of equipment i know
that so i run it up the chain of command
and i want to give you a bid on what i
can make for you so they ended up with
this process where i would submit the
paperwork for this new piece of
equipment and it would never get done in
time and by the time i'm able to get
back to you and say yep i can make your
equipment here's the bid you've already
found somebody else that can make it so
they had this big problem they'd cost
them a bunch of you know
millions and millions of dollars of
production that they could have done for
various contracts
so as they're explaining this piece of
paper i said well what's this piece of
paperwork so they say
well you know the paperwork goes into a
black hole corporate okay so i say who
and i'm sitting there with all the
executives
and the plant managers for multiple
factories
so i say okay who
you submit this piece of paper you
factory manager yep i do okay who gets
it and so someone raises their hands
and then they say okay you sign it then
where does it go and so then i figure
out the whole chain
and there's 10 signatures it's got to
get you know all the way up to the ceo
if it's a piece of equipment that cost
more than whatever the number was
and i said okay okay i said okay i get
it it's got to get signed i go let me
ask you this
once this piece of paper hits corporate
who has ownership over that piece of
paper
and the answer is no one
and therefore it's not a priority no one
gets it done they lose millions and
millions of dollars so like you're
saying anytime you have some kind of a
process that no one cause you what are
you going to say corporate's all jacked
up
okay but that doesn't help us solve the
problem we know that
what someone has to do is say hey i'm in
charge of la unified
the results that we get are on me and
i'm going to fix it here's the first
steps i'm going to take and we'll see if
they work if they don't work i will i
will make other adjustments
but you don't see that and we don't see
it anywhere in government really yeah i
mean even when you look at like the
structure of special forces like and ask
like what is the like what is the
purpose of special forces one is to take
certain highly motivated and uh you know
talented guys and
and make sure that they're very highly
trained to accomplish specific you know
critical missions but really like
there's a recognition almost in there
that when something is really important
and has to be done very quickly or
without you know with extreme precision
there's not a lot of room for error
sometimes you have to take it out of the
system you know out of the sort of
normal bureaucracy and the way things
operate in order to like have any
confidence that it's going to really get
done the way that it's supposed to
and that goes you know you guys have
your own uh procurement process you know
everything down to there you know to get
what you need
and it's it's this almost this
recognition that like you know the the
system is really built to sort of meet
certain metrics and if we can say that
like you know we've got a bunch of
things that are green instead of red on
the powerpoint you know and we've
accomplished our mission 85 percent of
the time then uh you know we're good to
go that's a highly efficient
organization but one of those 15 percent
just happens to be you know leaving tens
of thousands of americans in the hands
of the taliban for you know undetermined
period of time you know
um
it's
yeah well you go one step further
and what you have is the person that
should be saying hey this is all jacked
up here's the mistakes we made here's
what we're gonna do to fix it instead we
get biden standing up saying this is an
extraordinary success
quote yeah this is a quote extraordinary
success well and why not i mean other
than having some sense of honor but like
other than that why not yeah
because you know
in a sane country in a real country
uh with an actual functional media
ecosystem
um
and a citizenry that wasn't so deeply
politically polarized that they just you
know uh just are gonna
eat up and regurgitate whatever it is
they get as the party line that morning
people just saying that it would be so
discrediting
that it would be hard to continue his
administration after that you know like
forget about like the whole thing
happening you know
the whole thing happening joe biden
could have credibly said you know look
it's his problem it's his responsibility
he's the president etc um but you know
we're talking about this developing in
july and august and he came in in
january and there's a lot of other
things to like as you're onboarding he
could have credibly came in come in and
said look um here's the information i
was working with
here's where we were when i came in
we've done x y and z to try to prepare
for this um but
you know this this is a it's a crazy
situation
in a part of the world that like you
know obviously we don't have a lot of
resources and control and this is what
happened okay i think people would have
been fine with it and here's what we're
going to do fix it and here's what we're
going to do to fix it um
i think people would have accepted that
i think people would have been happy to
hear it i think people i would have been
happy to hear it i would have had some
respect for that perspective but you
know there's no incentive to take
responsibility like why would you like
the worst thing you can do is like give
you know i guess your political
opponents like an opportunity to say
that like oh yeah we told you you did
this wrong just say no you didn't just
say that this complete catastrophe was a
huge success
rely on you know x percent of the media
you don't need everybody you can take
some criticism but as long as you got
some mixed in there then it's a he said
she said and by the time you get to 2022
or 2024 actually by the time you fast
forward 36 hours there's some other news
story that you filled up the airwaves we
still again we still have american
citizen children trapped in afghanistan
and nobody cares i mean other than like
the you know the fact that we've got you
know we've we've got private citizens
you know like army special forces
veterans and other people who are going
over there and doing this job because
that by itself is just it's just madness
it's it's a completely insane thing that
you do not get in a country run by
serious people
yeah at save our allies by the way is a
group of guys working and tim kennedy is
one of them um chad robershaw there's a
bunch of guys that are like doing their
best to make stuff happen
i mean
you you come up with the question of
like okay so who who are these people
like who are these people who are making
these decisions you know we use words
like the establishment or um the elites
or whatever but like i would i would
give anything for some elites right now
i would love to have some elites i don't
know who these people are um but what we
do have some idea of how they think and
how they operate there's the famous you
know now infamous notorious fact that
the president of afghanistan who fled
the country uh with a plane that was so
laden down with cash that they had to
leave pallets of cash behind because
they couldn't you know couldn't hold
anymore in this cargo bay
uh that he he flees the country
president ghani flees afghanistan as the
taliban are coming in
and he was you know again notoriously
now the author of a book called fixing
failed states
and so he is the expert and i am assured
of that because once i found that out he
was also a you know he was a professor
of government and uh international
affairs you literally can't make this
you literally cannot you sent me a text
you sent me a text with that book
and i i i was just
you can't make this up yeah if you tried
to make a freaking twisted it's a monty
python python movie
that would be it
here's this guy who's who's fleeing a
failed state
with a plane full of money that he stole
as he escapes
leaving the citizens of this failed
state at the hands of a brutal freaking
prehistoric regime
[Music]
and
and he wrote that book
a book called fixing failed states
and he was educated in america
um went to colombia
he taught at freaking berkeley
you can't make this up no he that's the
thing he's like he's a completely a
creature
of our foreign policy establishment you
know he's not worked at the world bank
worked at the u.n
been through harvard and world bank
leadership programs i love that part
yeah
well i've been going uh really hard
on
um mcnamara you know i've been just
going deep on a bunch of books about
mcnamara and just what just because it's
just a total
travesty
and you know he he rolled in he had been
the president of ford which at least
that was
at least he had some like level of
i guess you could call that leadership
experience right obviously yes that's
leadership experience but you know he
was a numbers guy and he was went to
harvard and he learned about statistics
and he brought his little smart group of
friends in there
into
you know into the government during
vietnam and that's how they were running
the same thing it was just like this
academic group in there trying to
um
trying to solve these problems yeah and
trying to apply these dude
here you gave me some notes here this is
funny the um
so publishers weekly which i actually
was just talking about publishers weekly
real quick before before you get into
that um
like it before you say this part which
is it's brilliant and fantastic um
it's important to note that like so this
is a review of his book fixing failed
states you're about to talk about that i
went and i was curious how was this
reviewed by the foreign policy press
right and i went and looked
just almost universally brilliant
visionary you know foreign affairs the
cfr's magazine just everything just wow
this guy really gets it he really you
know this is the kind of world leader we
need i found one only one on the whole
internet
that was written at the time like 2010
or 11 from publishers weekly you're
about to talk about that have any
freaking sense at all but yeah go ahead
well
i i just covered uh i just did a podcast
where i covered publishers weekly who
they are where they came from it's been
around since 1842 or something like this
um it's sort of the
the core uh publisher trade magazine but
then it kind of turned into what it is
now which is they do these reviews the
reviews are anonymous the reviews are
blunt
because they reviewed my new book called
final spin and they actually wrote this
incredibly
good review right
and but
you read a review and you're like wait a
second who wrote this review i'm like oh
it's publishers weekly publishers weekly
they don't play around and if if thing
is bad they're gonna drop the hammer on
it
and and so
it's no surprise that this book comes
out by this [ __ ]
and it says uh here's the here's the
publisher's weekly review the authors do
a fine job in emphasizing the centrality
of a strong accountable state and
addressing poverty and under development
unfortunately their analysis suffers
from its heavy reliance on management
theory abstractions such as the power of
networks flows of information and
capital webs of value creation and
business school truisms
quote underlying a sound management
system is an effective supply chain
management litter their target
discussion fixated on new economy
conceits they say little about the
crucial task of quelling violence and
lawlessness instead they dwell on global
globalization-oriented development
strategies drawn from ireland singapore
oregon
and other regions that are not failed
states
dude
it's like yeah
then read the last line yeah that's
great too they even likened sudan's
travails to those of troubled
conglomerate conglomerate taiko
international
like the this shows you that these
people are idiots well here's what it
shows you actually because like the
thing is i guarantee you if you stat if
you sat in on one of those this dude's
classes at berkeley or johns hopkins
you'd say oh it's a brilliant man it's a
very intelligent highly educated man if
you sat down across a table and had
dinner with them
he'd be very sophisticated uh he would
be very eloquent in describing like all
of these things you say wow man i can't
even keep up with this guy he clearly
knows more about it than i do
you read that
and any
lance corporal and marine corps could
read that and say well that's insane
that is
insane that this this is the way that
this guy is approaching something like
we're talking about afghanistan here
yeah you know and he's looking like
what's singapore and oregon and you know
this like multinational corporation
taiko international up to but here's the
thing
i guarantee you
that when this guy walked into
somebody's office in the state
department to give his presentation it
was
oh their hearts left out of their chest
guaranteed yeah because
that little anecdote i love this
anecdote i share with everybody because
it is
it it gets right to the heart it's
emblematic of the entire you know uh
root of the issue with the way you know
that this group of people think and i'm
glad you brought up mcnamara because
again mcnamara himself is kind of
emblematic of something that had been
growing in the u.s system for quite a
while by that point right i think you
started getting like the first mba
programs in like the late 1890s or
something like that you start to get
this whole theory from like frederick
taylor and other people of like
management science and you know and all
this and in the idea this is coming
along it's like you know the the first
um the early progressive era is coming
up and you have all of these ideas that
like uh you know that that
really like a fundamentally different
way of looking at politics both
domestically and internationally right
there's there's the traditional way of
looking at politics which is that you
have a bunch of actors of relative
sovereignty they have different
interests they might have conflicts over
those interests and politics is the way
that we manage those relationships in a
way that hopefully tomorrow we're not
all killing each other and we can have
this discussion again
uh but people came along
and said well now wait a second here um
that is just a messy way of doing things
their way of looking at politics both
domestic and internationally is the
construction and defense and
administration of a system
and so they don't look at uh you know
sort of the world as like having you
know you've got various economic blocks
you've got russia over here with like
their interests and their sphere of
influence that they you know they
believe they should have control over
china and these various players and we
all have demand no no no there's a
global liberal consensus there's a
global system that exists and you can
either be like a rogue state somebody
who's not on board with the system and
that's the way that you know people see
somebody like russia for example they
don't see them as like this is just a
country that has a lot of interest that
conflict with ours and we've got to
manage that and deal with it no no no no
they're not on board with the global
system everything's about like you
construct a system you defend it and you
administer it and so these people are
managers and they judge their they they
they judge their uh performance by how
well the system itself sort of continues
to function whatever the outcomes are
it's how they think it's completely
insane to anybody with a modicum of
common sense
but you know these people you went
through years and years of graduate
school to pound that common sense out of
them because it's the only way you get
to a point where you think putting this
guy in charge of afghanistan is a good
idea he he hadn't been to afghanistan in
decades
and they bring this guy in
and put him in charge of the country you
know
again you could put
you know ralph the freaking bricklayer
uh in charge of making this decision and
he would know better than to do that
i was
i'm trying to think of what year this
was
my friend seth stone was at princeton
and he was getting his
degree in policy from the woodrow wilson
school at princeton and
i went out to do a talk with one of his
classes about
counterinsurgency and and so i'm i'm
giving the counterinsurgency talk and
going through and seth was with with me
we were actually doing it together we
were explaining what happened i i talked
about ramadi and then he talked about
sadder city which was i was in charge of
the task unit in ramadi he was in charge
of the task unit in sauder city
you know that's 2006 2008. anyways we're
going through this stuff and
and i'm talking about the sunnis and the
shias and the shia army and the
and the mostly almost 90 whatever
percent
sunni inside the city of ramadi and the
90 whatever percent shia army coming in
there and
i'm explaining why this is really hard
and
now we're starting to kill each other
and we got non-traditional murders
taking place and we got
shakes fleeing the country so i'm
explaining all this mayhem right
and i forget what the actual i wish i
could remember the way there was a woman
in the class that asked me a question
and
she set the question up
with
the basic
what she was looking for
was
you know this kind of academic solution
to this problem
you know you've got these sheets sunnis
you got them isn't it you know if you
got them to you know moderate and hire a
you know you brought them together and
she had this idea
and and i gave her some kind of an
answer
before i gave the class some kind of an
answer which was something along the
lines of i'm sorry to tell you this in
this esteemed
institution but there's not always an
academic solution to every problem
and that's so true right here yeah like
you think you're going to roll in there
and utilize the power of networks and
the flow of information and capital and
the webs of value creation is that what
you're going to apply to help you out
as afghanistan freaking derails and
turns into a
a bloodbath that's what you're going to
apply
an underlying sound management system
and an effective supply chain but that's
what we're going to look at no that's
not what we look at
the the thing about this and again not
to not to go so hard against princeton
or harvard or any of the other schools
but here's what we have to remember
princeton and harvard the rest of the
great colleges in america berkeley they
have produced incredible minds
and you have incredible people with
talent that come out of those schools
certainly
but i kind of look at it like the seal
teams
just because someone was in the seal
teams
right right now in the public light
right the seal teams are uh
in many cases held very highly in in
public opinion
but i'm gonna tell you that just because
someone was in the single teams doesn't
mean they're a great leader doesn't mean
they have great character doesn't mean
that they uh walk on water and it's the
same thing with any of these schools
just because mcnamara went to harvard
i mean kennedy went to harvard too
right but just because mcnamara went to
harvard doesn't mean he knows how to run
a war
and just because ghani
went to wherever taught at berkeley
doesn't mean just because he wrote a
book that used big words doesn't mean he
knows how to get a
country on its feet
in a short period of time i would say i
mean in many cases in this case it's
it's glaringly obvious it means the
opposite you've got to remember these
institutions are places that have
incredibly selective uh you know they
can have anybody they want come in there
the average like iq of an incoming class
at harvard something like 130. and so
are they producing brilliant people or
are a lot of brilliant people going to
harvard you know and you you start to
wonder like are we teaching these people
things that are making them worse at
stuff like this
detaching them from reality you know we
have like a leadership class that is
like
that that that you you know what it is
it's like it's like people have become
so uh uh like um like like like detached
from reality yes but like
sort of uh entranced by some of these
abstract theories and ideas about how
how the world works
um that they've convinced themselves
that you can like speak reality into
existence you know if you can say it in
a certain way and you've got sort of
like the research to back it up and if
the media reports on it in a way that is
favorable and so on and so forth then
that's reality and then you run into
actual reality which is a dude from the
from the pashtun waziristan mountains
with an ak-47 who's never even heard of
harvard he's
forget about his kids aren't going he's
never heard of it he's never heard of
massachusetts what he's heard about is
um you know uh you guys are wandering
around the mountains over here and i
don't like it and i'm gonna come chase
you out with my gun that's what he knows
and that's what you have to deal with
these people and their theories are not
prepared to deal with that yeah well
here's the other thing that
unfortunately if you're not careful you
can learn at these institutions
and that is a complete lack of humility
and so you look at mcnamara this is a
guy that could not comprehend that his
statistics didn't make sense you know we
i've consulted a company called echelon
front
we work with all kinds of people that
have been educated at the finest
institutions in america the ivy leagues
and everything else and
over and over again
i get told or people on my team get told
man
this is leadership you don't learn you
don't learn that kind of leadership and
humility and how to actually
navigate tough situations when you get
your mba or when you take a leadership
course
it's not the same thing
and the primary thing which i've said a
million times the most important
characteristic for a leader to have is
humility
so when you think you're going gonna
take your thing that you thought of and
it's just gonna overlay onto a situation
with perfection and you're not gonna
need to adapt to whatever's happening on
the ground and you don't actually accept
that's another thing i say a lot
the first thing you have to do is you
have to actually accept reality for what
it is not for what you want it to be hey
that you have a vision that's great
reality gets to have a play in that too
so
we're already at a disaster
waiting to happen
and the fact that our attitude was well
i think it'll take at least three months
for the taliban to be in control the
country and like you said now we're
going to tell the afghan military
and you don't think the afghan military
can sense that and you don't think the
afghan military once you pull close air
support away from them once you stop
giving them the logistical support that
they need to keep an aircraft running
because you want to talk about people
that don't know how to don't know where
massachusetts is but now we want them to
do the maintenance on a complex aircraft
that's not happening i mean you know
working for the dod on the engineering
side like people out there who don't
know i mean there's like you know a lot
of weapon systems that um we sell to our
allies highly advanced well-developed
countries
that they can't maintain without us we
don't give them the technical knowledge
they need to get parts from us you know
they're completely dependent on us and i
mean just just the way we train the
afghan military is it it makes you
wonder like what was
makes you ask the question of like what
were the incentives that were really
driving our decision making here you
know like you say what kind of military
did the afghan did the afghans need who
was their their enemy their enemy was
the taliban it was al qaeda and isis and
maybe some tribal uprising or something
like that that's that's their issue
if pakistan decides to send in tanks and
you know um and fighter jets and stuff
we'll bring a carrier off the coast and
we can handle that like this is their
their issue so what do they need they
need a crack light infantry
they need to know how to use like uh you
know mobility tactics with um you know
their vehicles and their helicopters
things like that and they need good
artillery that's really what they need
basically right and um what did we give
them we give them i mean we read some of
those things but like there's a lot of
other stuff like highly advanced weapon
systems that like
completely irrelevant but but
very expensive
you know there's some uh there's some
defense companies out there that made a
hell of a lot of money selling all that
stuff to them and it's stuff that's
irrelevant and we made them completely
dependent
on you know not only are you selling not
only are you selling them the system
you're selling them 20 30 years of
maintenance and parts and contractors
that are all run through you you're
setting yourself up with a gravy train
for the next three decades and you're
building an army that is
that expects close air support like at
any point over the last several years or
let's just say like the last two years
when we knew we were kind of on our way
out um you know did we start to deal
with the fact that like look we're not
going to be here to give them close air
support all the time we need to start
preparing them for that fact so that
they can deal with that they don't panic
and don't you know just or not even
panic just that they have like a plan
because i don't care who you are like
you can be like maybe anything short of
like a u.s force you put them out in the
field and then just overnight take away
their close air support when they've
been trained that like you get into this
position you call it in etc etc um your
morale is gonna is gonna take a serious
hit you know and um they're not gonna
like just work around that on the fly
and um
did we do any of that no
well why not well because like in the
moment you know there's an engagement
going on and uh we don't want the bad
news of like taliban winning this
victory in this place or whatever it is
and so we are going to provide close air
support and you just do that until you
don't
and
um you know and so what you have is an
afghan force for all you know all the
talk out there and people really need to
stop with this it's just infuriating
really
when people talk about how these these
cowards just ran away from the taliban
yeah the situation over there
you know when you're when your
leadership structure evaporates and when
your you know maintenance structure for
all of your equipment goes away when you
can't get parts for your equipment
because all those parts come from us
they don't have parts for these things
in afghanistan you know we withdrew all
of our contractors in june of 2021 just
you know a few months before all this
happened just that by itself lets the
afghan military know that like
we're done here we don't think this
thing is going to last you know and it's
one of the reasons by the way that like
it's it's very hard to take seriously
all the claims that they really thought
that this thing was going to last longer
than it did
it just you know the way we were
behaving in the lead-up to it there's
just much more of a concern with
perception
you know there's that famous call
infamous again call uh between president
biden president ghani that happened in
july and when you look at like what was
being said
publicly
at the time that this thing was going on
you know this is a time where there have
been uh you know we've had like
department of defense inspector general
reports coming out for months saying hey
the taliban are moving in these areas
they're massing for large attacks
um
and they're starting to take over like
provinces and mass against provincial
capitals and this entire time we're just
hearing that like things are going
smoothly and the biden administration is
planning its big september 11th party
because that's going to be the 20th
anniversary of 9 11. and now he got us
out of afghanistan you know the original
date of course was may 1st that we were
supposed to pull out according to the
original deal but around mid-april uh
they decided i'm sure partly because um
you know there were planning issues
because we just weren't prepared even
though we knew we were supposed to pull
out may first last year and a half we
weren't prepared for it um i think
probably they thought they could roll
biden once he got in there that they
could like get him to cancel and they
couldn't and so then they kind of had to
scramble at the end that's my suspicion
when you say they who are you talking
about you know like well i mean the same
people for example um who it admitted in
print um gloated in fact about lying to
president trump um throughout the last
year and a half of his administration
about how many troops were in syria
because they were afraid if they told
him that he would pull them out so those
people whoever those people are who
didn't want to leave afghanistan for
better or worse you know look there's a
case to be made that 2 500 troops and
some air support in afghanistan would
have been a good idea but but here here
nor there the order was to get out and
um they weren't prepared to do so
um you get up to mid april and uh
president biden makes the decision um
that we're going to move the withdrawal
date from may 1st to september 11th and
i think that the date there is very
it's very significant because it gives
you it tells you what
that there's a political angle to this
right it's not just a date of like well
here's when we're going to be ready
here's what makes tactical and strategic
senses it's obvious that that's not
what's going on this is a political date
and there were reports leaks from within
the white house that said that the real
you know the big part of the reason that
they moved the date was they at the time
you know uh the pulling out of
afghanistan was very popular and this
was going to be a big deal and uh they
want they didn't they want to be able to
say that like we didn't just follow
trump's plan you know and he sort of
like got it all mapped out and we kind
of like just followed it and so forth
they wanted to be able to say like
put your signature put your signature on
it and so they have their big you know
their their big party plan
on september 11th
and uh you have this phone call
right between president ghani this is on
july 23rd
this is after we've pulled our
contractors out this is um you know this
is a month before everything really just
goes completely to hell
we've had inspector general reports
media reports
uh
for for months now saying that the
taliban are on the move they're massing
for major attacks against provincial
capitals like the afghan forces are
collapsing i heard before you read that
i heard from one of my friends um
was saying that
the taliban was just like rolling up
outside of villages
a runner in saying hey we're here
um police chief or whatever
security force afghan security force
leader we're here uh you can put down
your arms all good will carry on or you
can fight us and we're gonna kill you
we're gonna kill your family and the
locals were like sounds like we're uh
supporting the taliban now yeah and they
were taking down their names and
information and uh you know just so that
if you stay cool and we'll be cool don't
start nothing won't be nothing i mean
these are people who understand how
afghanistan works you call these people
cowards these are just people who
understand the situation that they're in
you know
so yeah this phone call this is july
23rd a month before everything is
completely collapsing publicly at least
it's been collapsing for months at this
point
we have dod documents and again media
reports from bunts like that that show
that this is the case
and you have this phone call just an
excerpt from it that got leaked out to
reuters which is a felony by the way
whoever leaked that but um whatever i'm
still glad we have it because it really
provides a window into the into the into
the thinking here you have president
biden saying to president ghani in
afghanistan hey look i want to make it
clear that i'm not a military man any
more than you are but i need not tell
you that perception around the world is
that things aren't going well in terms
of the fight against the taliban and
there's a need
whether it's true or not
there is a need to project a different
picture
and so president ghani
how long do you want to talk about that
for right i mean well again
how long do you want to talk about that
for there's a need whether it's true or
not
to project a different picture that's
what we're doing yeah so like yeah like
like what is what is it he's really
thinking about there like what is what
is it he wants what is the thing that
what is the get that he's after here
from president ghani right he needs this
picture to be presented
is this because like um you know if we
present this picture of strength then
the taliban are going to sort of back
off no no no no the taliban are not
watching international news the taliban
are on the ground they know what's going
on that's that's not this is not a
strategic sort of we need this strategic
propaganda no um you know this is
something that like hey what we really
need is like i need i back here at home
i need there to be a different picture
presented you know and the reason again
that we know that is for months they've
he's been told you know that
reports have been flowing up for months
from the ig in the dod from every every
direction
that the country is in process of
collapsing and all they're doing is
going out in public and saying
everything's going fine you know we're
step by step on our way out of here and
you know we're going to be out of here
by by september 11th it's all going to
be great
um
when what's actually happening is i mean
they're you know they're less than
they're just a few weeks away right now
from uh again
i mean the the craziest hostage
situation in american history where
you've got tens of thousands of american
civilians in the hands of an enemy we've
been fighting for 20 years and so
president ghani says
mr president
this is his response to this comment
right
about whether or not it's true there's a
need to project a different picture and
he says mr president
we are facing a full-scale invasion
composed of taliban full pakistani
planning and logistical support and at
least 10 to 15 000 international
terrorists predominantly pakistanis
thrown into this so that dimension needs
to be taken account of
second what is crucial is close air
support there was a very heavy reliance
on air power
and you know we talked about that
already a little bit just that we built
the the afghan military to expect this
and to rely on it
and so right then
this this is a point where like to me
it's it's
you just had the president of
afghanistan saying hey it's we we're
under a complete and total invasion um
we do not have the capacity to hold this
thing off it is happening right now it's
got international support there are
international terrorists pouring into
this place and at this point there are
tens of thousands of american and allied
nationals in that country the fact that
we didn't do anything other than a full
government red alert
and say okay this now is no longer a
sort of uh withdrawal from afghanistan
this is a rescue mission
it's not even an evacuation this is a
rescue mission and we need to get in
there and secure enough enough places to
get our people out
and
the fact that that didn't happen
uh it's i mean you know i i
i put no amount of incompetence beyond
uh you know our government um but i
understand why the people out there who
are the conspiracy theorists look at it
and say there had been something else
going on you can understand why just
because like
it's it's a baffling decision except
again
from the fact that like this is the same
conversation where president biden is
saying we need to project a different
picture well if i go in there and say
hey
you know we need to go rescue these
americans i need 4 000 troops on a quick
reaction force to come in here and like
retake bagram air base because the
taliban had not occupied it yet we had
left but it was still in control the
afghan government at this point we could
have retaken that very easily
you know secured the kabul airport we
could have done all that but then well
oh well now well things are not going
well obviously and i'm going to have to
give a speech about that and i'm going
to have to address that and so they
don't want to do that what they want is
to project a picture that everything's
going fine
long enough for us to get the hell out
of here
and then if afghanistan collapses six
months later like who cares like you
know it'll be on the news for like a day
or whatever but like who cares
not not our politicians they don't care
you know you read about like um you know
what happened when we left bagram i
think it was like july 6th
and you have the afghans um afghan
officials who are saying that
we just left in the middle of the night
without telling them that we that this
was it we were leaving we left we shut
down
the electricity in the place which
created like a huge security crisis at
the time and there were a bunch of
prisoners that got loose and a bunch of
looting that happened until the afghans
realized what was going on realized we
had left we got on helicopters and like
flew out uh back back to the embassy and
then then to leave and they had to like
scramble to get control of bagram again
and
you know you're just like what is going
on here
it's it's it's again it's baffling but
again and i'll stick on this one more
time is like the fact that like they had
that phone call and president ghani is
telling him like this is a
this is a serious crisis we are in
complete collapse and there are tens of
thousands of not just americans but
french british australian you know a
bunch of our other allies who are in
that country
and not only is there not a full
government red alert emergency rescue
mission that is initiated
they just they just keep on like
everything's going fine did they tell
our allies about this phone call i doubt
it because the british and the french
and everybody else seemed real upset
when all of this started to happen and
they weren't getting you know good
communication from us
and so
you know again these are people who who
have learned over time to value
perception over reality you know and
have the i and really have the idea that
if you can just create a certain
perception and push it out there enough
that it solidifies somehow into
something real
and um you know when you occasionally
you can go on that way for a long time
especially when you're in the united
states of america you can float along on
fantasies for a really really long time
but occasionally you run into something
real
you run into the taliban or you run into
a putin or a she or somebody who does
not care what your you know what what
illusions you're weaving and now you got
to deal with reality and you find you
are not prepared for it
you um
you get this risk aversion
going on too where
it's all about damage control it's
almost like this is total damage control
right he is a little bit preemptive
because it hasn't fallen apart yet but
he's already saying look we got to make
this look as good as we can and then
it's cross my fingers and hope that we
can pull this off uh you know what's
interesting i i've been talking about
this a bit lately
um
i use this term default aggressive
meaning like you got to be default
aggressive to make things happen
and sometimes i'll work with companies
that's a bit much right it's like hey
wait a second we're gonna be teaching
our people to be aggressive
and the marine corps has a great
a great phrase which is very similar
which is
bias for action right which is
means the same thing kind of right hey
if i'm training you i say look you've
got to be default aggressive and make
things happen okay if i tell you hey
daryl i need to have a bias fraction
it's meaning the same thing
and then you could get right down to
like a more business buzz word you know
i want you to be proactive not reactive
right so there's there's different ways
of saying the same things
but
i'm holding on to being default
aggressive and now i've gotten to a
point where i explain why i use that
term
well i stick with that term it's because
if you're a young seal officer
and there's something bad happening
there is so much
so much pressure
on you
and and the easiest thing for you to do
your instinct is to not do anything like
there's bad things happening there is a
there is a a force on you this inertia
sits on you that i don't want to do
anything because just about every move i
make looks like it could go bad
and so in order to get you over that
hump
i can't just say have a bias for action
because bias fraction isn't strong
enough to get you over that hump of
doing something just saying hey i want
you to be proactive not reactive that's
not strong enough
the amount of weight that is sitting on
you telling you don't do anything you
better just sit back and it's it's
easier just to let it go as
just let's see what happens
that weight is so heavy that pressure is
so much
that it takes a phrase like listen dude
you need to be default aggressive you
got to make something happen to get you
to get you to break away from that
gravity
that human beings have which is we don't
want to do anything we don't want to
rock the boat if i make a decision it
puts me at risk i'd rather just sit here
and not do anything and just have events
unfold and i'll deal with what and you
can kind of sense that here with biden
things are obviously going sideways if i
was in this situation i would have done
what i said on that video which is oh
it's going bad right now cool here's
what we're doing we're sending shock
troops in there we're going to retake
bagram we're going to send out strike
units into all of afghanistan until we
get everybody we want we'll get them
sorted and when we're done
whenever that is
we'll leave
we're not playing by anybody else's
timeline we're doing what we need to do
to win and that would have been an
aggressive move
but
that's why because you can feel biden
who's never been any sick in any
pressure situation before you can feel
it matter of fact i guess the closest we
could say he he voted against the bin
laden strike right
yeah he was the one that was like yeah
yeah well the the the attack he wanted
to do the airstrike okay
so he's not he's already not a risk
taker he already sees you know for him
he's like the the the the military
officers that have been risk-aversed
their whole career and it's worked out
yeah he's been he's been in congress
since he was 29 right so you know this
is the it's his whole reality is like
how do you manage perceptions and so on
and risk aversion and what's going to
have the lowest impact and what's not
going to you know
no headline is better than a bad
headline right so no headline is uh you
know the stuff
if he crosses his fingers
maybe this maybe this goes okay
and he's just just not
sharp enough
to recognize what's happening as it's
happening
i mean don't you think so like i i think
on
that bias for action that default
aggressive i think is
you know you go go out there and talk to
captains uh you know uh oh threes o3
type captains go talk to majors and you
i think you see a ton of that oh for
sure right
um
as you start to filter up and there's
been good writing about this from like
tom rix and others that like you know as
you start to filter up the ranks
you know those guys with that default
aggressive like at some point along the
line no matter how great they are
there's going to be something maybe you
know a lot of times along the line that
up you know it doesn't go right and
they're the ones who made the decision
they're responsible for it and um you
know they've got a million times that it
worked out and the situation was saved
because of them but now you got this one
thing and now they're going up for o5 or
o6 against somebody who doesn't have
that mark
and so once you start to get to a
certain level especially when you start
to talk about generals and admirals and
people who get past that point to be uh
you know a centcom commander a chairman
of the joint chiefs or a secretary of
defense
is you have an entire layer of people
who have gotten where they are by being
politically sensitive and managing their
risk and making sure that anything they
do
even if it goes wrong they can always
say well yeah but
you know some because
you know and you can say like so it's
almost too much to ask like somebody at
that level to you know it's not like
these people got to that level and are
like you know i better i better learn to
manage risk no that's who these people
are by that point you know you've gone
through your whole career and gotten to
that point that's who these people are
it's what defines that that that class
of people when you get up to that level
and you know you ask yourself like how
do you overcome something like this and
you probably speak this better than i
can but you know from being within the
bureaucracy myself the dod bureaucracy
for quite some time um
there's one way you overcome it because
it's the nature of bureaucracy to
operate this way right you know when you
have like a human resources department
as opposed to like a boss who just kind
of promotes the best person you have to
go through certain things check boxes
to a certain extent like there's got to
be this risk aversion you know and and
or at least just it's just it's the
incentives that bureaucracies provide
right and so uh you know you have like
everybody who kind of like uh well how
how do you overcome it the way you
overcome it is that you have somebody at
the very top
who says look um if something goes wrong
it's my responsibility i'm the one who's
responsible for it i will take
responsibility all the way up and down
the line if something happens
your first thought need not be who is
going down for this
because as long as you've not you know
gone and thrown a baby off a cliff or
something nobody's going down for it if
you were going out there and taking
action you know in good faith to try to
accomplish this mission or do what i
asked you to do
you will not be the one held responsible
i'm responsible and then people can go
roger that and they can go do their jobs
but if you don't have that at the top
and clearly we did not have that at the
top here then everybody is really like
you know i mean it's easy it's easy to
say that like you know people up and
down the line just should have taken
initiative but really they're being told
not to i mean they're really the signal
that's being sent is not to do that it
would be ridiculous to do that because
the president doesn't have your back the
secretary of defense doesn't have your
back general milita all the way up and
down the line is just a group of people
above you who if anything happens
they're going to be looking for somebody
to put it on and so people are
responding to that incentive
and you know it's it's
again it's the nature of bureaucracy but
the way you fixed it is with strong
leadership and it was
to say it was lacking here is uh you
know just an understatement of the
century
yeah well that's the zero defect
mentality right of hey like you said oh
you're you're a default aggressive
platoon commander there uh cooper cool
great oh you did a great job here you
did a great job there oh you you saved
the day over there oh wait a second you
went a little too far over here your
career is done
and literally done right and i'm
literally done it's over like you're not
getting promoted again and then you're
eventually getting so who gets promoted
people that didn't take risk and also
people that obeyed and didn't push back
right because i say cooper i want you to
do this i want you i want you to put
your troops at additional risk um that's
what you need to do and you go roger
that sir okay great you get promoted
yeah oh i don't want you
you you want to go out and take the
fight to the enemy you know what cooper
i just want you to stay back and just
stay inside the wire and just make sure
you guys are okay i'll do that sir
i don't feel like we're really happy
helping the afghan people i don't really
feel like we're helping the iraqi people
it doesn't matter cooper what i want you
to do is keep your keep your troops safe
um don't make any mistakes
and it'll be a great deployment you'll
get your bronze star and and we'll get
you promoted the system can desist to
function
you get someone that's
like you said one mistake
because they're they they do 99 things
great they make they make one one call
out of 100 and it goes sideways that
person's not getting promoted which as
an officer means you know yeah you're
getting drummed out you're getting
drummed out this is and everything
you're talking about is really the
essence of decentralized command which
is look daryl you go out you know what
the intent is you go out if you execute
inside the intent that we have
you're good
you're good
that's what it is are you are you gonna
be held accountable if you do something
stupid or you do something nefarious
hell yeah i'm gonna destroy you but if
you go out and you're executing based on
what the intent based on my intent i got
your back 100
100
so go make it happen we're not we're not
promoting like that anymore that's why
we don't have a patent you know a modern
day patent a modern day chesty pull or a
modern modern-day joshua chamberlain
none of those guys would have been in
that position today nope you know
so that's a nightmare
that's a nightmare um and and what's you
know another note on this is you know
i'm a
battalion commander i'm a brigade
commander whatever
you're a brigade brigade commander so
our job my job is to train up number of
afghan troops so
i get my afghan troops
i train them up i get them to a point
where
you know what they can kind of patrol on
their own
they can kind of patrol on their own
with a minimum number of advisors so i
get done with my deployment i turn over
with you but i send my report up that
says i got my afghans to a point where
they could patrol with a very small
number of american advisors
and
great
i turn over with you
you see my report what do you do on
deployment
you know what you do you do a little bit
better than me
maybe not in real life
but on paper you do a little bit better
than me because if i'm your now now the
overall commander i said daryl cooper
what happened jocko trained these guys
up to where they could do patrols with
limited number of advisors and you you
said the same thing so you didn't really
do anything
jack already did that so what's your
report says your report says i trained
instead of just a jock only trained 400.
he trained one battalion i got three
battalions that can now do operations
with limited advisors okay that's good
job daryl
you're getting promoted
and what's the next guy doing he's got
them so that they can do raids and
patrols
so we end up in this situation where
we're
expanding on the truth and it's not just
bottom up right there's there's top down
pressure for that as well 100 i got a
report you know the the brigadier
general says you know i've got a meeting
i've got to present to the four star uh
this weekend he wants to know uh that
we've met specs you know it met met the
quota for trained afghan soldiers like
for the last quarter i want to see green
instead of red on that powerpoint
because powerpoint is how information
you know it comes to people at that
level and so he tells that to a colonel
or lieutenant colonel who tells it to
the major on the ground who's like there
and knows that like oh these guys can't
read
a lot of them can't count to ten
there are tribal issues like
interoperability issues with these units
that like if we didn't have americans
watching over them i'm not sure that
they wouldn't start killing each other
um and so on and certainly they're not
going to risk their lives for each other
and so on and so forth he knows that
but he's got pressure from above saying
um look are you gonna be a problem for
me you know the general really wants to
hear this like don't be don't be the
[ __ ] for me you know you're making my
life hard
and um you know the guy may be in good
faith i mean we all want to say that
like oh you should just
be the one who steps up but like you
know there's a guy facing one to eight
years in prison right now a marine
lieutenant colonel for uh going on
youtube with a video and saying people
should be held accountable for this
so i mean
there's no incentive to do that you know
and that's the reality and so like in
you know short of like there being like
a mass strike or something like for one
person to stick his head up the system
is just not built to incentivize that
yeah and it's also not necessarily a
nefarious thing where you know daryl
cooper takes over from jocko
and
he's going damn you know like
i only trained 400. why is that oh
because the turnover rate like the
iraqis they turn over all the time you
get people that would be in the army
they're supposed to be serving for a
year they'd serve for two months and
then they'd bail they'd desert so
instead of reporting the truth about
what's happening it's like well we start
feeling like
hey i could do a little bit better and
there's also other things that happen
in ramadi we're training the iraqi
troops well as we're training the iraqi
troops guess what else we're doing we're
killing bad guys so ramadi itself is
becoming more pacified which means that
they actually can do more patrols they
can act a little bit more independently
and it was a nightmare sometimes in
ramadi they would turn over
um let's say a checkpoint to iraqis and
as soon as the insurgents would see it
was oh it's all iraqis there they would
freaking attack and they overran some of
those positions while we were there was
a nightmare so yeah so we got very
paranoid about
saying these guys are ready we got very
paranoid about it because we knew the
insurgents knew if we said that these
guys are out there on their own they're
gonna get they're gonna get rolled up
um but even that even even with that i
sometimes think about what some of the
reports that i sent up the chain of
command and i'll give you an example
they weren't great like they were not
good at planning the iraqis
the iraqi soldiers they didn't really
have a good
handle on coming up with a plan and i
remember sending pictures up the chain
of command this is myself putting me on
report right now of like hey
here's a picture of you know some iraqi
soldiers doing plan because they we used
to we used to send pictures
of the iraqis
every week
that were used for exactly what we're
talking about here's you know
here's 40 iraqi soldiers doing
marksmanship and it's it's to paint this
picture of progress
and
i remember sending up a picture that was
like here's some iraqi soldiers and
their officer coming up with a plan for
an operation
and they're looking at a map that they
had no idea what they were looking at so
there's me
doing that right there's me doing that
now the line that i didn't cross was
like hey these guys are ready to go on
their own i did i couldn't do that
because i knew what the outcome would be
but but me trying to do a good job oh
you want to see pictures of these guys
planning okay cool here's a picture of
these guys planning they don't know what
north is on a map but here's a picture
of some iraqi soldiers that can't read
they're planning a mission it's like it
was [ __ ] yeah so
but but then you take that little
sliver of jocko bending the truth a
little bit and saying hey iraqis are
doing some planning
but then you multiply that times
20 years
and you end up with a bad situation and
then you get like uh
very difficult
to be the person that says hey man these
guys are not ready now we did i did do
that sometimes and i'll tell you an
example they were like hey can you teach
these guys one of them was like
can you teach these guys
to do biometrics
after a direct action mission i was like
no this is not possible they're not
going to be able to operate this
equipment they're not going to be this
is not possible we cannot do that
long-range shooting
hey can't you get these guys to a point
where they can take you know 500 yard
shots no we can't
we're not doing that not only do we not
think they're capable i don't think
that's smart
the last thing i want is to have one of
these people that we trained
turn those weapons back on us we're not
doing that
so there was like a line for me but
still even i pushed that line a little
bit
and so now you take that you multiply it
times 20 years and times multiple
iterations and one of the worst things
about all these modern wars that we have
since korea is that we go on deployments
and then we go home
world war ii you went
and you stayed for two years three years
four years and you stayed until we won
starting midway through korea it was hey
you've been here for a year you can go
home
and now what are we trying to do we're
just trying to get through that year
vietnam same thing hey you could do a
year you can go home okay so what's
what's the how's that attitude change it
changes from trying to win to trying to
survive
and that's a that's a
that's a big transition and the so it's
not only trying to win
changing from trying to win to trying to
survive
you also lose this continuity and when
you lose that continuity
even guys
you know i've got friends that did
6 8 10 12 i got a friend that did 19
freaking deployments
19 deployments but guess what each one
of those deployments is broken up by six
months or whatever back home there's no
continuity there
that that afghan unit or that iraqi unit
that you were working with is a lot
different in six months people get
killed people desert people get promoted
it's just there's no continuity
or very limited continuity yeah you know
we've been trying to uh manage an empire
for a while but we're a country who
doesn't want to be an empire we've never
really wanted to be you know empires
require things like viceroys and
regional governors and stuff and we
don't we don't think of ourselves that
way we don't want to be that way in any
kind of a conscious you know conscious
sense and so
we're at war for 20 years
and what are we doing we're fighting 21
year long wars
and because we just don't approach
things that way and it's it's a yeah
it's a tough trap i mean but it's a it's
a maybe it's a lesson to us is it like
look this country does not want to be an
empire and if your war is going to take
20 years then
you probably shouldn't do it because we
just as a as a country with our
political and social system the way it
is like we just don't seem able to
sustain our motivation through it yep
well even a low-cost war like this one
relatively speaking
a big mistake that we make though is we
view everything through western eyes and
we view a western outcome
and
that's like
the wrong move
you you we can't do that
and um
what we want for the outcome to be is
this western
vision
and it's very difficult to achieve that
in a generation can you get can you move
in that direction in five generations
yes you can what does that require it
requires a perm a
permanent presence on the ground
for a long period of time now you kind
of
you know shrugged your shoulders a
little bit out the idea of hey we could
have left 2 500 in air 2 500 troops on
the ground and we could have left air
support there and yes we could have and
if we had done that
the taliban would not have been able to
take over the country at all there's no
question about that and then you have
like we we kind of talk about the bagram
airfield as a
method to complete
the evacuation
that place is also a strategic airfield
in this right in the middle go look at a
map
of of southwest asia
and look what's in the middle of it
freaking bagram airfield you have access
to just about every country around there
so it's a strategic airfield not just a
not just a tactically superior airfield
to extract the people the americans out
there but it's a strategic airfield that
you can utilize for
all kinds of strategic missions massive
you can fly fleets of any aircraft we
have in and out of that place relatively
easy to protect so
we
spent like a billion dollars on that
thing yeah and and and this idea again
one of the
one of the phrases that got thrown at us
from the politicians was we're going to
end these forever war this forever war
the forever this wasn't a forever war
this wasn't a forever war
the american soldier hadn't died there
since february 2018
we'd gone okay and look every freaking
soldier that dies is a travesty
but when you've worked that hard
but it's not just a sunk cost fallacy
either it's not like we've worked that
hard to get there we got there
we got there this wasn't like oh we've
we've put a lot in here but we should
just finish the job the job was kind of
done
what we needed to do is maintain
some sort of presence there
so that we don't say oh it looks like
the taliban's going to rule in two
months
or seven days or four months or six
months the taliban is not good
the taliban is not good
so when we have a thought that maybe the
taliban is going to be in control of
this entire country
ho
we shouldn't allow that what's it cost
to us what's the cost going to be for us
to not allow that oh well we got to keep
a couple thousand troops on the ground
we got to keep air support there well
guess what well isn't that going to cost
money yeah it costs money
you know you wrote this kind of funny uh
thread and i don't even know when you
wrote it on twitter about how you know
how about some training grounds
you know what about why don't we use
this for training
it's it's a funny idea right but
you're gonna go on deployment
as an american you're going to go on
deployment if you're going to go on
deployment why don't you go on a
deployment instead of going on
deployment to germany or going on
deployment to guam or going on
deployment to korea or going on
deployment to the philippines which we
all deploy to all those different places
why don't you go on a deployment where
you're actually maintaining the security
inside of a country and keeping that
country stable
so that you're being utilized for a very
good reason
and your presence and your deployment
and your separation from your family has
real value to it and you're gaining
useful experience and you're gaining
useful experience
on top of that
that's a beautiful thing so maybe once
of every month
um an american a10 has to go out and do
some close air support
they were going to do that close air
support in herbert field florida by the
way maybe an ac 130 has to go out and
protect some afghan troops from being
overrun by the taliban
that's going to cost money yeah they're
going to have they literally go and do
that
in
the chocolate mountains in southern
california that's what we do so why not
go out there and actually have your
presence
be utilized in a powerful way
because now what we end up with is a
a government that's the freaking taliban
and here's another thing that i've tried
to point out to people
i always say if you're doing the right
things for the right reasons you're
going to win in the end and this is true
and if you're a leader and you're trying
to
help people
you're going to
end up in a better position
and if you don't let your ego get
involved and you take care of the people
below you in the chain of command and
above you in the chain of command and to
the left and right of you in the chain
of command if you're doing good things
you will end up
being promoted you will end up running
things you'll end up with more
responsibility and it will end up good
for you
and that is 100 true now could you
occasionally hey you know i i gave
darryl credit for something and you know
he actually just said yeah you're damn
right i did this and he got promoted
cause that happened occasionally yep it
does it does but then guess what next
round everyone realized daryl's a a an
arrogant guy that's just looking out for
himself and no one wants to work with
you and it it's gonna bite you in the
long run
so that applies
that rule of treating people well
and taking care of each other applies
and works
in benevolent situations
if you are
a gangster
if you're in the mob
if you're a freaking drug dealer on the
streets if you're a gang member
the person that is most ruthless is
going to rise to the top
so what do we have in the towel because
because everyone's like well you know
the taliban it's the taliban against
isis k against al qaeda you know who's
going to win there the most ruthless
of the players are the ones that are
going to win and they're the ones that
are going to end up in power
so
if the taliban isn't extreme enough and
they're not willing to just do whatever
to to just
murder rape torture kill they will be
surpassed by whoever is ready to murder
rape torture and kill that's what's
going to rise to the top in the country
of afghanistan
and we are going to be sitting here
hanging on to
the the freaking
destruction
that comes from it
um we got to talk i know we've been
running a little bit long on this so we
got to talk about the the denim model
this whole situation because there's a
the what denim like the uh unraveling of
the whole situation at the very very end
right um there's a uh
you know there's a part of me that's
almost that almost would have
taken the attitude
that uh
i'm almost glad it fell apart as
precipitously and obviously
catastrophic as it did at the end as
opposed to six months from now when it
would have been on page six of every
newspaper and nobody would have cared um
because it
unmasked and kind of laid bare the
incompetence and the in the bad
priorities and just everything else of
the people making these decisions except
for the fact that a bunch of people got
killed as a result of this at the end i
forget the fact that like
you know tons of people are being killed
today by the taliban going door to door
and pulling people out of their houses
if you believe everybody in the
government that was going to happen in
two or three months anyway so let's just
call that like something that was baked
into the cake we had a bunch of uh
marines and a corpsmen and
another 180 or something afghans uh
civilians of course all killed by this
suicide bomb one soldier to you and one
soldier yeah and um
you know this is a this is a situation
where um
it speaks again to like what it was at
the
what the priorities were here right you
have a situation
where um
you've got a bunch of our people let's
just say exactly what it is like you had
american forces
and american civilians
and foreign uh you know civilians who
were hostages of the taliban in this
situation they controlled who went in
and out of that airport they had enough
personnel in that city that if they had
decided to storm the airport they could
have done it there would have been
consequences afterwards and so we you
know we had that deterrent effect but
let's just call that situation what it
is we had a bunch of our people at the
mercy of the taliban
you know you had uh you know president
biden some of the military and dod
officials being asked like are we
relying on the taliban for security
and they had to admit yes we are
so that's a situation that we put our
people in putting our soldiers uh
and marines you know just our forces in
general uh in a situation where they are
relying for security on the people that
until like i don't know today this
morning i guess we were telling them uh
you're at war with
that that's just a betrayal of
unimaginable proportions it's
unforgivable
and it's it's especially unforgivable uh
you know given what ended up happening
you have uh august 15th is when bagram
was taken and then the cu and then the
taliban storm into
kabul
it's just chaos in the streets the
president of afghanistan flees the
country
this is when you start to get those
pictures
of hundreds thousands of people clinging
to those c-17s as they were getting out
people falling down from hundreds of
feet in the air
which i know this is grim and kind of
disgusting to think about but it really
was like a dark
bookend uh with you know the people
falling from the towers on 9 11 to this
global war on terror as it's been
presented you know the people falling
and then those people i couldn't help
but get that that image was just stuck
in my head seeing that
and so that's when all this is going on
and at this point you've got tens of
thousands of americans and a bunch of
our forces literally at the mercy of the
taliban they can just
in the sense of like the taliban get to
decide what happens to these people
that's the situation that we put them in
and um the next day after this happens
this is when biden goes on for the first
time and uh blames the cowardice of the
afghan military and so forth for all of
this happening the white house press
secretary at this point by the way still
on vacation um you know biden has like
just gotten back maybe from camp david
or something and august 17th you start
to see these news reports people from
not just news reports but public
statements from political officials in
defense officials in france in australia
in britain saying we can't get the white
house on the phone we got a bunch of
people over here and we can't get them
on the phone so they start executing
their own rescue missions
you know uh
i i don't know what's going on behind
the scenes with our relationships with
some of these countries right now but
from what you know came out in the
public they were not it's going to be
it's going to take a while for us to
make that up to them i mean the fact
that like it happened without us
communicating to them that this was in
in process of happening and then just us
having
you know we were the ones
we were the ones with the forces to
control the situation we were the ones
responsible for this right um and then
to just let it unravel the way we did
without communicating with them and like
without telling them leaving their
citizens at risk i mean thank god you
got like the french gign who you know
from what i understand or pretty hua who
are going around like getting their
resident uh getting their civilians and
a bunch of other people actually i think
as well like good
the fact that we did not address the
situation with the same level of urgency
that these people did at the last second
it's just maddening it's insane
um august 23rd this is after they've
been in control for a week and it's just
kind of chaos and nobody really knows
what's going on the cia director meets
with taliban leader bharadar
you know uh
the the the the minutes of that meeting
have not been released but given the way
everything kind of played out you can
kind of put uh two and two together and
figure out what's going on there which
is we were making promises to the
taliban about what we would do and not
do for them
if they would let our people please
please pretty please escape afghanistan
um we talk about why didn't we destroy
all that military equipment why uh you
know why didn't we do a lot of things
well the taliban had tens of thousands
of american hostages that's why we
didn't do it and um that's the situation
that we put our people in and so then
you get to august 26
and that's when a suicide bomber uh you
know
blows himself up and 11 marines one
soldier one navy corpsman and 170 other
people were all killed
150 plus more wounded
um
and
you know you do you remember the the
press conference that biden gave
the day that happened or the next i
think it was maybe the next day that it
happened
it was just he comes out and it's all
very somber you know we're all just
just just very very saddened by the
tragic sacrifice of these men and women
which find that's all true and that's
great for the funeral uh there are um
still thousands and thousands of people
there right now surrounded by the people
who did this and um that's not what i
it's not what i wanted to hear i wanted
to see somebody stride out to the
platform and say okay enough enough
games enough [ __ ] um here's what's
going to happen okay we are landing
forces right now they're going to push
out a security perimeter etc that's what
what i want you didn't get that
why because you know you have to you
start to wonder about these people's
priorities and what's really driving
their decisions
i mean like you know you get to like
think about like uh
the the um
so shortly after the day after
um the suicide bombing
we somehow miraculously um
find the you know the building the house
that
first of all we find out who it was the
isis k leader who who hatched the plan
to do that suicide bombing we find out
who he is he's in jalalabad like 60
miles or so due east
we don't have any intelligence assets on
the ground so i don't know how he did
that the cia eagle base in kabul had
been destroyed like you know over the
last couple months and had been
completely finished like in the you know
in the weeks prior
everybody as far as we know is at the
airport like who can who can get there
so what intelligence assets we have on
the ground i don't know but somehow
somehow magically within like 24 hours
um our our intelligence people who
couldn't um who didn't have enough
information to understand that the
taliban was actually going to collapse
the afghan government and create this
this crisis somehow magically within 24
hours they figure out who the isis k
leader was who hatched the plan for the
suicide bombing and locate his building
60 miles due east in jalalabad and we
hit it with a drone strike
um
hooray you know maybe that was part of
the meeting that we had with the taliban
like you're going to tell us at least
somebody worth killing here and um
you know
we'll make it worth your while i don't
know
um
but i want to talk about
sorry excuse me some of my eye there
i want to talk about how the day
of this suicide bombing went down
um
because there were i sent you
a series of text messages
that were coming in there was a there
was a pro marine corps you know veteran
um instagram account that published
these things they protected the names
and the pictures and so forth but these
were text messages coming in
from marines who were there in kabul as
all this was going down
and they're talking about this situation
to this guy and and i've actually like
heard somebody um a guy that i that i i
have been following for many years about
15 years who i trust and i've spoken to
before who spoke to the uh guy who runs
this account and his to his satisfaction
verified that all this is true and
and um and so i have i've full
confidence that it is
and so these are text messages coming
from um marines in kabul to marines back
in pendleton and other places describing
what's going on there as it's happening
i don't know if you'd seen these before
i sent them to you but i hadn't seen
them it's really a cherry on top of the
whole thing and uh
it's maddening it's just it's absolutely
infuriating and maddening when you read
them yeah i mean
um jumping into some of them you got a
guy that's
stateside why were you guys police
calling meaning like what's a police
call is like cleaning up
i don't know i don't even know how we
end up calling that because you'd say
like police up that area right that's a
so they keep talking about how they are
made to clean and so a marine that's
over there came from higher we had the
police call the pax terminal where the
civilians were processed we didn't even
get rooms to stay in like the other
units we slept in the gym we picked up
water bottles mre trash and [ __ ] paper
re-flip vehicles to upright positions
um
fast forward a little bit we were
supposed to leave last night the general
cancer law flight because the base was
dirty
what the [ __ ] yeah i'm not joking we had
to clean the base for the taliban i'm
about to call my congressman that's
horse [ __ ] please
i want to but i don't want repercussions
um
fast forward a little bit
so we drop a bomb on the ring leader in
less than two days and took out a vb ied
today but couldn't stop the s vest that
we knew was coming for two days
all day on the radio it was a countdown
this is what it gets really disturbing
is so the s vest meaning the suicide
vest
he's talking about the fact that we
ended up bombing that vb ied which ended
up not being a
talk about that in a second but we had
bombed the one that you referenced
out in kabul
and
here we go or where was it wait where
was the uh where's that strike sorry
jalalabad
so he's saying we couldn't stop this
s-vest that we knew was coming for two
days
um
well everybody says you know he says uh
the marine gets back to him and says
that's how i was back in the day he's
kind of responding to what he was saying
first he says that's how i was back in
the day but those days are over brother
then he says wait what there was a
countdown yeah and he says yeah pretty
much it wasn't that accurate but it
happened an hour after the last radio
transmission about it they said 10
minutes an ied is about to go off two
minutes an ied is set to go off and at
16 27 an ied is gonna go off
then at 17 30 something it finally went
off they knew what the guy looked like
apparently and what he was carrying
that's very typical of intel to be like
look
it's not going to be 100 accurate
sure but but when you start hearing
reports of what's going to happen you
have to take those things seriously
especially when you get multiple reports
you get some kind of a countdown like
that they were requesting permission to
push out a security primer and being
denied it
while this suicide
vest is supposedly coming in on this on
this countdown this is when they're
being told hey you guys go police the
area this is all the same time this is
going on
um
so you guys knew
i won't let anyone know where this came
from but we have to let this known
brother
this is the amer this is the guy that's
in america the picture you posted is
true we had the police call even though
there was credit credible threat of the
possible s fest and up to 10
military-aged male came over the abbey
gate wall with aks then we got on packs
we got back on packs set up a security
posture and then
then they still had dudes go back and
continue police calling
again that means cleaning so we got a
major threat and we're trying to set up
security and they go hey no but come
back over here and clean we got guys
coming over the gate
with aks
and we get told no
and part of what cleaning means here by
the way i think maybe it's in there
later i can't remember if i included it
is you know we're not just talking about
cleaning up water bottles and stuff
they're talking about they were making
them go around scrub off any graffiti
where people had written like [ __ ] the
taliban or [ __ ] isis because they didn't
want to uh i guess leave any
inflammatory messages behind
so compare that with your iwo jima yeah
anecdote by the way
you can see they're just here's a marine
saying i re-enlisted a year ago but i'm
wanting out man i want to do something
that actually makes a different
difference not work for a corporation
that doesn't give a [ __ ] about my guys
we've run into countless people who've
said that's what we signed up for it's
no big deal or this wasn't biden's fault
or why set up drinks in a bar for people
like that half the country cares half
the country doesn't give a [ __ ] america
is beyond [ __ ] up
amer the guy that's in america says
brother i served two and i served in 2-1
for eight years deployed with them four
times there's always going to be people
like that
people that don't like us and don't
respect us but you are still a light and
darkness and no one will be able to take
that from you this freaking stateside
marine is trying to
he trying to lift up the head a little
bit of this marine that's overseas the
marines overseas says i'm trying man i'm
waiting to hear if my buddy makes out of
surgery right now my other buddy died no
one cares this [ __ ] sucks
another marine chimes in the s vest
countdown is no lie
i heard occasional radio chatter of them
saying how far away the bomber was
absolute incompetence we had a carl g
which is a
recoilless rifle it's like how you take
out you could take out a vbid with it we
had a carl g and literally had to steal
rounds because we weren't given them our
position got faced with [ __ ] 10 plus
armored vehicles with diskas
only a couple hundred meters away and we
weren't even given carl g rounds despite
pleading with the higher ups we were
doing quote patrols with a fire
team-sized element with no a a presence
and passed that that convoy with however
many personnel that were accompanying it
within 100 meters no assets or isr jack
[ __ ]
our team leader didn't even have a radio
if we got into a contact we were told to
just send a runner
another marine chimes and yeah we had to
clean up the airport for the taliban
sad how they told us quote that's what
our fallen brothers and sisters would
have wanted
left the sour taste in my mouth
they said that
america the stateside marine says yeah
we we had to cover up everything that
said [ __ ] isis and the taliban because
quote that's not what the fallen would
have wanted and they say the same thing
but for cleaning
another marine chimes in it's super
[ __ ] up because at first we were only
taking people with visas green cards or
us passports then we just started
letting everyone in because biden wanted
a number quota
and once we hit that quota we stopped
they totally [ __ ] the people with the
actual siv cases
marine there's another marine that
describes uh
sending desperate afghan civilians back
to the taliban
and the stateside marine says how are
you holding up emotionally he says not
great i've had a really rough job
that the news fails to show i have to
drag men and women and children and
fathers and mothers pleading and begging
for their lives out the gate to the
taliban because they aren't on a list
another marine describing the same
situation pushing back fathers holding
crying three-year-old boys as he pleaded
with me and all i could do was hold the
kids hands or hold on to his shoulder
and tell them i'm sorry but he had to
back up
people so [ __ ] desperate for me to do
what i wanted to do but i couldn't
because the nature of what we're doing
grown men and women with babies asking
us to kill them because they'd be
happier getting killed by us than the
taliban
people handing us babies and running
away trying to get into a line and
abandoning their children
or worse leaving them to drown in a
waist-high river of [ __ ] because they
wanted to cheat and get up closer to the
next step
the final marine says
i can tell you some guys are really
gonna struggle when we get home
and then you know you mentioned briefly
the lieutenant colonel sheller
that's
right currently in the brig
because he posted a video
basically asking for accountability
i don't
i think then he continued to post stuff
i think he got told not to post stuff he
continued to post stuff they put him in
a brig i think the last thing he posted
was have the mps standing by for me
um
you know
this is uh uh very
i mean it's almost it's almost the exact
same thing that david hackworth did that
got him drummed out of the army right he
went on the news media
and said if we don't change how we're
fighting this war we're going to lose
and he got drummed out of the army in a
month and he was the most highly
decorated freaking soldier they had he
was
um
you know a post two-time battalion
commander in vietnam
he was
one of the most he was probably the most
respected officer in the army at the
time when he did that
and he got drummed out of the army ended
up going australia i mean it was a bad
scene
um
and here's here's the problem so what do
i think of that
there's always the debate
and i have i have this with with
hackworth himself right if he wouldn't
have done that he probably would have
become a brigade commander he would have
become a brigade commander division
commander he could end up with more
influence
but
how many more americans would have
died during that time and and and this
is exactly you know somebody i was
getting interviewed and somebody asked
me about uh lieutenant conor scheller am
i saying his name right is it sheller
yes
um
we
we that's great you know hey
just be professional um you know run it
up the chain of command
you know stay
do what you're supposed to do
i get it
i get it i get that advice
i get that advice i understand it i can
understand if i was giving lieutenant
colonel sheller counselor say hey listen
bud listen bro
i know
you know you want to speak out right now
let's no not get emotional let's um you
know uh try and run it up the chain of
command you know keep your influence
you're in charge of a battalion you
wanna you don't wanna leave these guys
in the in the lurch
um that's great
and you can say that
but and this is exactly what i wrote
about with with hackworth and when i
wrote the forward to that book
you get to a point
where
you can't do that anymore
and hackworth got to a point where he
had seen
so many young american studs and i used
that word specifically because that's
what he called the soldiers he loved he
called them studs
and he he had a way of classifying
people as either studs or duds
so how many
hundreds of his beloved soldiers did he
see wounded or maimed before he said you
know what [ __ ] this i'm going to talk to
the press
and so
lieutenant colonel sheller he's been in
for
18 17 years he's a battalion commander
that means he was a company commander
that means he was a battalion ops
officer that means he was a company xo
that means he was a platoon commander
that means he was a
that means he has served over and over
again for 17 years his entire military
career we've been at war
and how many of his
men has he lost
and that is a [ __ ]
helpless feeling
and so now you're in a situation where
you see
some of your beloved marines get killed
and you want someone to say hey look
here's the mistakes that we made here's
some things that we should have done
different here's how we're going to
prevent it from happening again
and look if you're in a military
situation and your commander says hey
this is what went wrong this is what i
screwed up here's the mistakes i made
here's how we're going to prevent it
from happening again
you don't you you go okay
cause you know what lieutenant colonel
sheller when he was a
second lieutenant or a first lieutenant
or a captain he didn't do everything
perfect and he knows that
but guess what he got held accountable
he held his men accountable
so for me to pull him aside and say hey
look bro just let's keep it professional
there is a point where that doesn't work
anymore and he reached that point
now
i've had guys reach that point with me
by the way i've had guys come to me to
talk to me about what we were doing and
how we were doing it
i didn't want to do something a certain
way or thought we should do a mission a
different way
and you know what you do when someone
gets to that point you know what you do
you listen to what they say
you listen to what they say you listen
to what they say with humility
and you say thank you for giving me that
feedback let's sit down and figure out
how we can address it
you're saying this is my fault i agree
with you this is my fault
when someone comes to me and says hey
jocko you're in charge this went
sideways this is your fault the answer
is yes it is yes it was my fault
here's what we're going to do to fix it
can you help me come up with a plan i am
going to listen to what you have to say
the worst possible move to make is tell
that person to shut up
the worst possible move to make is tell
that person to stay in their own rank
the worst possible move to make is to
suppress what they're trying to say
and and and
turn that person into a martyr
that's not a good move
what we do is we take ownership
we're not seeing that happen right now
well there was a need
whether it was true or not to create a
different perception so you know
that was the priority at the time and um
so i misspoke earlier when i said that
nobody was held accountable in this
whole shitty situation one person was
and that was the person who actually
spoke out and asked for some
accountability
um
now i'll say this
there may be
there may be
someone in the marine corps that's like
all right here's what we're doing
take shell or put him in the brig
i'm going to handle this [ __ ]
i've done that kind of [ __ ] before i've
been like oh cooper did this all right
cooper hey come here you're on
restriction here's your punishment and
you're like damn and i'm like yup shut
up that brings back memories yup here
here's the deal
you're on restriction you screwed up
you're gonna you're gonna take a hit
right now
and i'm gonna be able to handle this
the marine corps might be saying that
hey listen man they're out for blood
right now this is what we got to do
freaking
that could be happening
it doesn't look like it
um anybody that knows me
knows that i actually love the marine
corps
without
any reservation
so i hope that's what's happening behind
the scenes it certainly doesn't seem
like it
but
there is still time for redemption
there's still time to move in the right
direction
and all of that starts with taking
ownership of what is happening
and we need to see some of that and you
listen to that guy talk i mean what you
see is and again like there's a guy who
understood the consequences of what he
was doing he understood perfectly well
uh that he was stepping outside
and on on his own and making himself
vulnerable at a very explosive time and
i think he willingly accepted the
consequences when he did that
um
but there you know there comes a time
where
the system itself is broken down so
fundamentally and you look above you and
all you see are people lying
and all you see are people who are
interested in covering themselves and
papering over mistakes
and
you reach a point when you've had people
that you cared about bleed enough
in realizing that
these 11 marines this soldier and these
in this sailor who were killed let alone
the 170 afghans who were killed that for
the people who are making the decisions
up there that this is a public relations
problem to them
and at a certain point you just you
can't you can't just keep keep your
mouth shut anymore
you know and again i'm not saying there
shouldn't be consequences for that kind
of thing you know sometimes that's what
you know makes a martyr righteous is
that he takes the consequences for the
decision he makes um
but
this is just you know there was such a
fundamental and total systemic breakdown
that like it's it's hard to imagine how
anybody uh you know it's hard to imagine
why there weren't ten thousand
lieutenant colonel schiller's out there
you know
well because the
there's a lot of pressure yeah and
there's also
everyone's people have that debate in
their minds like oh well how bad is this
will i be able to do more good
by speaking up or by toeing the line
building relationships doing my job
getting promoted getting to a point
where i can prevent this stuff from
happening that's a legitimate question
of are there some people that are sick
i'm not saying anything
because they're just weak yeah of course
there are
so
it's a horrible situation to see unfold
and it's like you could say that
anything's changed as a result of him
doing that so the people that made the
decision were you know well there's an
interesting i i want to say it was
actually
uh
i think it was
well when mcnamara was president
there was a marine
that
would speak out against what his
policies
to him personally and at one point he
got asked well why didn't you submit
your resignation
and he said well if i submitted my
resignation i would be in the headlines
for 24 to 48 hours and then no one would
know anything and i'd lost all influence
i had over the situation
so there's people that are doing that
right now too
and
i hope that between the people that are
speaking out or the individual that's
speaking out
and those people that are trying to work
it from inside the system and trust me
there's
all kinds of incredibly patriotic brave
and outstanding
character
humans inside the army inside the marine
corps i know them i know them
and they will do their best to make this
stuff right through their own
methodology
so
the the only other thing i mean this is
a obviously a podcast that we could talk
about for
a very long time
the the only other thing i'll say is
this or
the last thing i'll say right now
from a strategic perspective as a human
being
as a nation
as a
former military person
as a dad
the idea of imposing your will on people
the idea of imposing your will on
subordinates the idea of imposing will
your will on your kids or your family
the impo the idea of imposing your will
on other people
and the idea of imposing your will on
countries
seems expedient
it seems exceeding it seems like the
easiest way for me to rule my platoon is
to say hey everyone shut up this is what
we're doing it seems like the easiest
way to guide my children is to say shut
up this is how i want you to do it it
seems like the easiest way to
build a nation is to say shut up this is
what you're going to do now
and even if you made those statements a
little bit nicer and took away the shut
up and you just made it this is what
you're gonna do this is how we're doing
it this is what you owe me
this is the way you're going to run your
country
even if you made it nicer than that
if what you're doing is essentially
imposing your will on other human beings
it is going to be a fight and it is
going to be a struggle and it is most
likely in the end not going to work now
if i am a tyrannical leader
i can make it work for some period of
time
i can make my subordinates fall in line
for some period of time i can make my
children obey my commands for some
period of time
i can make a nation behave the way i
want them to behave
for some period of time and during each
one of those periods of times i have to
be there watching
imposing threatening
but the human will
cannot be underestimated
not in a child not in a subordinate not
in a country
and if we underestimate that human will
we are going to end up
losing
you impose your will on your children
you're going to end up with a rebellious
kid that's doing nothing that you asked
them to do or nothing that you wanted to
do you end up with subordinates that you
impose your will on all the time with
the minute they get the chance
they're not doing what they're supposed
to be doing
and they're going to push back against
you you're going to have a
mutiny and a nation
you and try and impose your will
you can impose it when you stand over
them with the sword
and by the way that's what the taliban's
gonna do right now
they're going to stand over that nation
with a sword they're going to impose
their will
and as long as they impose their will
with violence and threats they'll be
able to maintain control we've seen that
before
what did saddam hussein we covered that
on this podcast saddam hussein imposed
his will on his country with a sword and
with chemical weapons
so that seems like the most efficient
way
but it's not
it's not the most efficient way to lead
your children your family your platoon
your team your company or a country
so when we roll into these countries and
we think that the best way for them to
be is the western way
it's not the right answer you can't
impose it on people what you have to do
is you have to allow people to discover
the truth for themselves
that's what you have to do you have to
allow them to see the benefits
of the way things are going
that's what you have to do and it takes
longer
takes it appears to take longer
it appears to take longer
but in the end it is
infinitely more efficient
and that is a
attitude that we haven't quite figured
out yet
many leaders haven't figured out on a
personal level in their family many
leaders haven't figured out in a company
and we as a nation certainly haven't
seemed to figure out yet
that
in trying to impose our will forcefully
is less efficient
than allowing countries to develop
and find the truth for themselves
and learn for themselves the benefits of
freedom learn for themselves
the benefits of free thought
and if we allow them to do that that
will be a lasting cultural change
not imposed by us
but grown from their own minds
and therefore
therefore
inherently becoming a part of the way
that they live
and that is something we need to keep in
mind
and we need to keep in mind and i know
this audience is going to have any
problem with that
that
any criticism we might have for uh some
of the leadership decisions that are
taken the marine whose text message we
read is correct that you know the
sailors soldiers airmen marines who are
out there you guys are a light in the
darkness
and um nobody can ever take that away
from you
that is the absolute truth
all right
i think that's it for now
um thanks for tuning in everybody
we appreciate it thanks for subscribing
we're sorry we haven't gotten much of
this done
we've been
busy
which sounds like a big excuse to me but
um we're working
in the meantime
some of the things we are busy with is
our other podcasts i have a podcast
called the jocko podcast i have a
podcast called the warrior kid podcasts
i have a grounded podcast and i have the
jocko underground which you can access
through
jacounderground.com daryl has another
podcast
and his podcast is called
martyrmade and he also now has a
subscribers only feed
at martyrmaid.substack.com
and you can support all these podcasts
through
daryl's sub stack
you can also support these podcasts by
getting some gear
from jacquesstore.com or
originusa.com or from
jacofuel.com which we are drinking these
tasty beverages right now i'm pretty
deep right now i've been podcasting for
quite a long time today
and i also have a leadership consulting
company that can be found at
echelonfront.com
and that is it for now
thanks for listening to us
as things unfortunately
continue
to
unravel this is jocko and daryl until
next time
out